welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of
ghostbusters afterlife directed by jason
reitman son of ivan reitman who directed
the films in 84 and 89 the latter of
which young jason actually cameoed in
you know my dad said you guys are full
of crap jason well some people have
trouble believing in the paranormal no
he just says you guys are full of crap
and that's why you went out of business
of course being a nod to his dad as this
new whole film is on a macro level a
tribute to absent papa's spoilers ahead
manifested in his film in 70 opacity by
the likeness of the late harold ramus
egon spangler reconnecting with his
descendants and his fellow busters the
reason this final reveal hits so hard is
all the subtle ways afterlife is rooted
in ghostbusters inside jokes production
design and mythos so let's go through
this movie scene by scene to break down
all of these overlooked details because
well boston makes me feel
so good the film opens with familiar
music composed by rob simonson who
actually said he deliberately aimed to
evoke the eerie score of elmer bernstein
from the 1984 film simonsen's trapped
track features spooky piano notes chimes
and synth
[Music]
[Applause]
just like bernstein's music in the
opening library scene
[Applause]
[Music]
little touches like these just stoked
that nostalgia for the original like a
nice warm chocolate bar blanket in
somerville oklahoma fuchsia clouds swirl
over a peak beyond the old shindor
mining company just like the clouds over
550 central park west in the 84 film as
gozer arrived now shandor was the name
mentioned by egon in that film who
explained that building's whole history
the architect's name was evo shandor i
found it in tobin's spirit guide
and then in 1920 he started a secret
society and he wasn't alone he had close
to a thousand followers when he died
they conducted rituals up on the roof
bizarre rituals intended to bring about
the end of the world and now it looks
like it may actually happen and they
talked about how that building had
selenium girders which were chosen as
conductors of spiritual turbulence
selenium that was mined here in oklahoma
where it is later implied ancient
worshipers of the sumerian deity gozer
built a hellmouth ages before the united
states even existed and why egon
returned here to try to trap gozer which
he does here using one of the terror
dogs as bait but his trap field
generators short circuit by the way in
that clip the tobin spirit guide that
egon mentions is the same book that the
kids later read to learn all of this
history now in this opening scene we
never fully see egon's face only his
silhouette with a curl of white hair
over his forehead much like egon's look
in the animated series but no dialogue
is spoken just pure visual storytelling
which makes this opening scene more
frightening than one would expect
especially when egon's chair grabs him a
callback to the demon chair arms that
grabbed dana in the 84 film the reason
he is in this chair is that he is
guarding the trap that he hid in the
floorboards beneath the chair and his
pke meter psychokinetic energy meter
lights up to mark this spot and a signal
that egon's ghostly presence remains in
this house with unfinished business
egon's daughter callie carrie and
his grandkids trevor finn wolfhard of
stranger things and phoebe mckenna grace
are forced to move out of their city
apartment to somerville phoebe wears the
same round glasses that egon wears which
this film later underlines by having her
literally put on egon's glasses directly
over her own and they drive past the
diners spinners where the light is out
on the word shakes ironically most
likely caused by the shakes the town is
experiencing from these supernatural
tremors egon painted on the sheet metal
of the gate of his farm revelation 6 12
and the words of that bible passage
that's actually the corrected version of
when rey in winston talked about
revelation 7 12 and 84 film i remember
revelation 7 12 and i looked as he
opened the sixth seal and behold there
was a great earthquake and the sun
became as black as sackcloth and the
moon became his blood and the seas
boiled and the skies failed inside the
house is a super high stack of books of
course a callback to the library and the
84 film you're right no human being
would stack books like this there's also
a statue of one of the terror dogs which
in that movie did take the form of
gargoyle statues now all over the walls
of this house are numbers finding these
same numbers in the gozer temple these
kids later deduce that these are
actually dates of historical freak
occurrences 1883 1883 the eruption of
the volcano krakatoa 1908 1908 the
tuskoga blast in which a mysterious
meteor air blast flattened to forced in
siberia rey actually mentioned this same
event in the 84 film you have been a
participant in the biggest
interdimensional cross rip since the
tunguska blast of 1909. yes ray said
1909 but it really was 1908 1945 they
say what didn't happen but was likely
referencing the atomic bombs dropped on
japan 1984 gozer's arrival in new york
and now 2021 goes return but this movie
was originally going to release in 2020
so they must have had to vfx change this
to 2021. annie potts returns as janine
melnitz who says of egon your father
wasn't much of a homemaker he could
hardly keep the power on literally that
is how egon died his electrical
generators failed cutting off power to
his trap field janine is also a bit
vague about how close she was to egon
and nod to their flirty relationship in
the first film egon's ghost connects
with phoebe using a chess set initially
a nod to the real ghostbusters animated
series in which egon loves chess but
never has anyone to play with also in
the comics egon faces death in a game of
chess meanwhile trevor uncovers the
ecto-1 car in the barn later in this
car's glove box they find a twinkie of
course a reference to egon's twinkie
line in the 84 film let's say this
twinkie
represents the normal amount of
psychokinetic energy in the new york
area
according to this morning sample it
would be a twinkie
35 feet long weighing approximately 600
pounds
that's a big twinkie at summer school mr
gary gruberson paul rudd has the kids
watch the 1983 film cujo based on the
stephen king novel about the killer dog
of course foreshadowing the terror dog
that will chase gruberson later on
callie meets with the town shopkeeper
jack who's played by tracy letts carrie
coon's real-life husband and an amazing
character actor in his own right on the
town cinema marquee are the movies bingo
and cannibal girls cannibal girls was
the 1973 horror comedy film directed by
ivan reitman and this film also showed
up on the movie leader marquis in
ghostbusters 2. phoebe finds igo's
hidden trap and brings it to school
where now the horror film child's play
is playing and she researches the old
ghostbusters commercial from the 80s
film on youtube if you look over on the
right some recommended videos on the
sidebar include 10 signs of government
is run by shandorians meaning the
conspiracy theorists of this world
believe that gozer cult has taken over
the government maybe it has then where
are the ghostbusters now with it looks
like present day images of dan aykroyd
and bill murray in that thumbnail proton
acceleration with megan amram megan
amram is a comedy writer on shows like
parks and rec and the good place and
savage science of the proton pack with
adam savage from mythbusters and a
thumbnail that looks like it's from his
tested video on youtube trevor and lucky
hang out at the top of the mine shaft
and hear a voice from below that croaks
the name goes
goes her spiritual form in this movie
was played by canadian dancer emma
portner and voiced by iranian american
actress shorey agudashlu while her
physical corporal form was actually an
uncredited cameo by olivia wilde phoebe
follows the pke meter to egon's
underground workshop accessible by
sliding down a fire pole just like the
ghostbusters had in their converted
firehouse office among his collections
are petri dishes a reference to the
hobby egon told janine about i collect
spores molds and fungus there's also a
door sign reading made i need room
service that was on the door of
bankman's office in the 1984 film from
here on egon's ghost possesses the lamp
where he is able to literally illuminate
knowledge for his descendants to finish
his unfinished business and phoebe finds
her grandfather's ghostbusters jumpsuit
and in the pocket are his glasses that
of course match her own and a crunch bar
wrapper go back to the candy venkman
gave egon
you've
you've earned this
also on the desk is a replica of egon's
dirt farm in-house evoking the town
miniatures that we saw in the attic in
beetlejuice and of course the town
square replica doc brown built and back
to the future but here we learned that
the property's reputation as a dirt farm
was in fact its literal function and
intent no plants grew there because
traps were buried in the dirt it was
designed to be a graveyard resting place
for the ghost gozer phoebe and podcast
test the proton pack switch me on
switch me on is exactly what rey says to
egon in the elevator
switch me on
here i just love the extreme close-ups
of all the elements of the pack and
phoebe's little struggle as she pulls
the gun out of its holster meanwhile
podcast dramatically draws his
microphone as his signature weapon
nothing's deadlier than the spoken word
podcast wears rey's goggles he's very
much the rey of this crew down to ending
the movie more cover than the rest in
marshmallow goo and adorably connecting
with rey over his podcast that found its
voice in the 46th episode now this would
normally be when i interrupt the video
to push you to like buy socks or cutlery
or mobile games but good news i'm not
gonna do that this time instead i'm just
gonna ask you a huge favor to support
something that really can make a
difference in this world something that
means a lot to me these new rockstars
recently partnered with a really really
great non-profit based in gainesville
florida where most of our team met in
college like no joke new rockstars would
not exist without that gainesville
community so we want to give back and we
hope you will too community spring is a
501 c 3 nonprofit organization dedicated
to dismantling structural poverty and
spurring economic mobility at a
grassroots level they focus on providing
income to meet people's needs and
providing power to reshape the systems
that keep them down and this week new
rockstars is going to be matching all
donations that you make to community
spring we believe in their work so much
that philip and some members of the new
rockstars team recently went to
gainesville to work hands-on with
community spring we shared some of what
we've learned about storytelling and
content creation with them and phillips
set them up with their very own blue
dungeon so that they can make their own
video content hot damn and we're gonna
keep visiting and working with them in
2022 we truly believe that the great
work that they are doing in this
community can be its own spring that
flows outward and cultivates growth and
opportunities and change across the
country in the world so many viewers
reached out to us the last time i talked
about community spring and they were
really thrilled with all the support the
new rockstars community showed them and
now is such a great time of the year to
be thankful for what you have and look
to help some folks that could really use
it we really hope that you will join us
in donating to community spring and show
them how awesome our viewers are so
click the link in this video's
description to learn more about
community spring and please donate
because again new rockstars will match
all donations made to them this week so
jump on this right away and we
appreciate your support thank you they
follow a trail of ectoplasm to find the
ghost muncher of course this movie's
version of slimer in this case actually
voiced by josh gad jason reitman said
that they wanted to restore the slimer
character from what he turned into which
was the dalmatian the firehouse
essentially back to the angry scary dude
that he was supposed to be originally
which is why muncher now has multiple
limbs and burps metal chunks of them
like machine gun fire podcast says free
floating metal muncher definitely class
five calling back ray's description is
slimer sir what you had there it was
what we refer to as a focused
non-terminal repeating phantasm or a
class 5 full roaming vapor real nasty
one too class 5 refers to the cdi
classification system that goes up to
class 7 for malevolent demonic entities
that are probably gonna kill you but
class five are the lower mid-level less
dangerous but non-humanoid forms their
chase and capture of muncher is awesome
and it mirrors the original ghostbuster
chasing slimer in that it causes a ton
of damage but does end up with the
team's first official trap muncher even
kind of anoints this moment by spraying
the ecto-1 with a fire hydrant that
clears the dirt off the ghostbusters
logo reflecting how this team is dusting
off the ghostbusters legacy and muncher
was really the key to that renewal the
way slimer was the key to their first
break but they get arrested by the
sheriff domingo lucky's dad played by
bokeem woodbine also that front desk cop
deputy medjug is played by stella
aykroyd dan aykroyd's daughter the share
of references of course the tagline of
the original films by offering the kids
their one phone call who are you gonna
call
uncle and phoebe does actually call a
ghostbuster dan aykroyd himself
returning in his race dance in his
occult book shop from ghostbusters 2
down to the red desk phone on his armist
tattoo the revelations passage chapter
and verse he mentions having been in the
slammer himself calling back when they
were jailed in the first movie and he
says their firehouse office is now a
starbucks and that winston went into
finance bankman teaches at suny
meanwhile gruberson picks up ice cream
at walmart baskin robbins uh not to paul
rudd's mc role as ant-man scott lang of
course worked at baskin-robbins and i'm
sure the company is well aware of this
product placement baskin-robbins always
finds out and he freaks out watching the
stay puft marshmallows coming back to
life but instead of in giant form in
miniature form because we did actually
see dana buy a bag of these things
earlier in that movie these things are
freaking hilarious the first one before
it bites his finger face plants onto the
shelf and it leaves these adorable
little circular imprints on his belly a
few others you can see rolling a can
away some others riding around on a
roomba actually run one over they impale
each other with umbrella skewers one
shoves candy in the other's mouth and
you can see him kind of cringe like he's
not sure if he likes it some of them
roast themselves on a barbecue grill and
one gives a thumbs up like the t-800
they melt a bar of chocolate on one who
loves it like he's in a warm way didn't
like it and then one jumps into blender
and turns himself into a goo but still
smiles the terror dog vinsklortho the
keymaster chases gruberson out of the
walmart a chase very similar to lewis
tully's run in the 84 film down to the
stop-motioning movement of the dog as
his stumbles crashing into stuff the
kids have to release muncher from the
trap to get their gear back out of
impound and the ecto-1 drifts around the
corner as it does when it speeds out of
the firehouse in the first movie and of
course it drives past a mural of the
stay puft marshmallow man in the town
back in the mind the kids witnessed
gozer's rise and the corpse of evo
shandor resurrects played by jk simmons
who doesn't get very long in the movie
because gozer rips him in half meanwhile
cali finds egon's photo wall of her as
the kid in the workshop and she gets
possessed by the gatekeeper zul just
like dana in the 84 film she even says
there is no mom only zuul a callback to
dana's line
she also wears a similar golden dress
that sigourney weaver wore and the
gatekeeper and keymaster bang in this
movie as they do before chaos erupts
throughout summerville there's an old
timey ghost and a minor hat who probably
worked in the shandora mine he was
designed to be a throwback to the taxi
driver ghost in the 84 film there's also
an eyepopper ghost modeled after the
real ghostbusters action figure when the
kids strategize podcast straps on the
colander helmet that louis tully wore
the aura video analyzer the goserian
alter bears the same triangular pyramid
stair step architecture from the 84 film
phoebe distracts gozer with her nerdy
jokes as podcast uses the rc card trap
to snatch the gatekeeper spirit they
drive past the spinner's diner but the
light up sign now just reads sinners as
the evil spirits have overtaken this
town and back at the dirt farm the
generators short circuit again but they
are saved by the arrivals of the
original living ghostbusters suited up
ray's stance dan aykroyd peter fenkman
bill murray and winston zidamore ernie
hudson when gozer asks if they're gods
bakeman says come on rey and rey finally
says yes a callback to his mistake in
the 84 film are you a god
no
then
someone asks you if you're a god you say
yes they refer to gozer as flat top as
they did before and immediately cross
the streams this time but ultimately it
falls to phoebe who gets an assist from
the ghost of her grandfather egon with
the resurrected spectral form of the
late herald ramus but rather than the
actor's actual appearance in his later
years they instead feature an aged up
form of his angular face from the 80s
films meaning that they had to use
archived footage of reymus from those
movies as a mass which they could then
animate on its own with additional
layers of aging this design choice was
made according to reymus's daughter who
gave her blessing and said jason reitman
wanted to make sure it was the character
of egon and not remus himself and they
really pull it off largely by having
egon never actually speak which they set
up in the no dialogue opening because
that is where past vfx resurrections
you've seen in other movies of deceased
actors often get stuck in that
uncomfortable uncanny valley really
bringing back remus as a ghost was
actually how bill murray wanted bankman
to return in the third ghostbusters
movie egon also became a ghost in the
real ghostbusters animated show at one
point and then in one of my favorite
shots in the movie egon's ghost lines up
with his fellow ghostbusters they all
turn and smile at him rey apologizes for
not believing him bankman just gives him
a knowing smile in real life bill murray
reportedly made up with harold remus
after a years-long feud between them
that started on the set of groundhog day
but right before reymus passed away in
2014 murray showed up to his place with
a box of donuts to make amends i don't
know if this moment was a direct homage
to that i'd just like to imagine that
might have been running through murray's
mind and egon dissipates and floats up
into the heavens as the kids watch in
awe mirroring the final heartbreaking
moments of the e.t which the composer
said he even tried to evoke with the
score and the words for herald appear on
the screen as we return to the opening
shot of new york city from the 1984
ghostbusters film with of course ray
parker jr's theme song now there are two
post credits scenes in this movie first
sigourney weaver returns as dana running
that same psychic shock therapy test on
venkman with the cards that he used on
the male and female test subjects in the
first film bakeman messes up that he
always just shocked the guy and then
after the credits we briefly see a
deleted scene from the 80s film in which
janine gave spangler her lucky coin from
the world's fair in 1964 and then we cut
to janine holding the second coin that
she said she had at home as she meets
with winston who reveals he has been
financing raise a cold bookshop and he
welcomes the ecto-1 back into the dusty
old firehouse as a red light blinks on
the red containment unit leaving the
door open for future installments with
the title-like afterlife this film truly
was the more optimistic take on death
that rightman's ghostbusters has always
embraced a true life after supposed
death in a tribute to a franchise that
has meant so much to so many support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis and breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you